AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME.
REMIX -A- LOT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
TODAY MARKS THE RELEASE OF NIKKI
MINAJ'S NEW ALBUM "THE
PINKPRINT," FEATURING THE MEGA
HIT ANACONDA, WHICH SAMPLES
THE CLASSIC SIR MIX-A-LOT LINE:
>> "MY ANACONDA DON'T WANT
UNLESS YOU'VE GOT BUNS HUN."
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Chris: ONE OF YOU IS LIKE NO
I HAVE A SNAKE,AND HE LIKES
BUTT CHEEKS.
SI COMEDIANS, I WOULD LIKE TO
YOU THINK OF AS MANY WAYS TO
FINISH THE LINE "MY ANACONDA
DON'T WANT NONE UNLESS ...
AS YOU CAN THAT OF.
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND GO.
SPIKE.
>> UNLESS IT'S GLUTEN FREE.
>> Chris: POINTS, SIR.
JESSIMAE.
>> UNLESS IT COMES WITH
UNLIMITED SALAD AND BREAD
STICKS.
>> Chris: YES. POINTS. PEREFCT.
DONNELL.
>> UNLESS IT'S COVERED BY OBAMA
CARE.
>> Chris: ALRIGHT.
POINTS.
JESSIMAE.
>> MY ANACONDA DON'T WANT NONE
UNLESS THERE IS ENOUGH FOR
EVERYBODY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JESSIMAE.
>> MY ANACONDA DON'T WANT NONE
UNLESS YOU ARE THE KEY MASTER.
>> Chris: POINTS.
SPIKE.
>> MY ANACONDA DON'T WANT
NONE UNLESS YOU DON'T KNOW I'M
TALKING ABOUT MY [BEEP]
>> Chris: POINTS.